welcome back to fox and friends a new
wall street journal report says the
biden white house is mulling payments
of nearly half a million dollars to
illegals separated at the border back in
2018.
republicans were quick to bash the
policy as unacceptable and
quote pure insanity joining us now to
react is arizona attorney general mark
bronovich welcome mark appreciate you
joining us here this morning what are
your thoughts on this idea that we would
pay almost half a million dollars to
people separated at the border who came
here illegally which by the way is
almost fifty thousand dollars more than
what we would pay
the family of a fallen soldier
in in our wars so what do you say to
that
it's unconscionable and what the biden
administration is doing on the border is
really quite frankly
unthinkable and unconstitutional rachel
um we have this terrible
crisis that's turned into a catastrophe
and the bite administration is now
trying to monetize people coming into
this country illegally so that'll end up
with even more people trying to cross
our southern border illegally but
essentially you know and i know this is
all about the biden administration the
far left trying to redistribute wealth
in this country so they're subsidizing
people breaking the law coming into the
country illegally we're going to get
more of that and they want hard-working
american taxpayers to pay for it as i
said it's unconscionable it's
unconstitutional mark i know you've
thought about this i i get i understand
what you're saying what you think the
rationale is but just even from the
initial reaction that we've seen from
americans over the last day or two since
we've heard about this
it's wildly unpopular politically why
are they doing this
um i i'm not sure i think that um you
know one of the things that we learned
in school or we used to learn in school
before critical race theory was jammed
down parents throats is that you
shouldn't succumb to peer pressure and i
think the far left the aoc's you know
the chuck schumer's nancy pelosi's uh
cartel kelly and the democratic party
are essentially far left the neo-marxist
and they really believe that they they
want to redistribute wealth they want to
make up society and they don't care they
want to destroy the middle class of this
country and they're going to do it by
any means necessary and that's that's
what this is and what breaks my heart
and i know you know this um in arizona
we're seeing a dramatic increase in
fentanyl deaths among teenagers in pima
county it's now the leading cause of
death replacing you know car accidents
even suicides and that's coming to every
state in this country
every taxpayer is going to pay for this
not only their tax dollars but through
their families health and well-being
yeah not to mention that we're rewarding
people who brought their children here
in a very irresponsible manner
let's move to another topic because this
one's very important this migrant
caravan that is on its way to our border
they say it may go to del rio but there
now reports that it can come to yuma
arizona mark i have friends who live in
yuma arizona they can't even get in
their children into their local hospital
they have to travel hundreds of miles
away because they're just so overwhelmed
at the hospitals and so many social
services are strained
what are you doing there in arizona to
prepare for this caravan coming through
and are you doing anything to stop it
well you know we're trying to use i'm
trying to use all the tools at our
disposal that includes multiple pieces
of litigation trying to force the by
demonstration to continue building the
wall and just yesterday the u.s supreme
court agreed to take our peel our case
about the public charge rules the public
charge rule the bind administration
rescinded which basically says if you
come here you've got to be able to
support yourself you can't be on public
benefits the bite administration by
eliminating that rule is forcing or
overwhelming hospital systems in yuma
all over the border all over the border
states because they're having to pay now
for benefits everything from you know
child care snap hospital care and the
system's overwhelmed and so there's no
way it's unsustainable the cartels have
gained essentially operational control
of our border and it's not just as i
said about the fiscal cost it's about
the cost when you have drug cartels um
that are operating with impunity on our
southern border and so we know and you
know that there's going to be a record
amount of people illegally crossing our
border more than two more than two
million people this year
it's unsustainable yeah absolutely it's
wrong
um mark thanks so much for joining us
this morning and bringing attention to
both of these very important issues
that are right here coming to our border
thank you so much